like
you've gotten obviously critiqued for
using the n-word
writing your music and [ __ ] all the time
all the time like
is that something that you've uh evolved
on at all i've heard i listen to your
music like the new [ __ ] i never
understood i
learned to ignore it because it's like
at the end of the day that's how i grew
up that's how i was raised the
environment i was raised
and there's a is a saying that i always
say they threw
tarzan in the jungle and he came out
like that you know what i'm saying
he didn't come out a different way there
was like it doesn't matter what the
environment you raise
you have your own action and choices no
it doesn't it
doesn't it does matter your environment
makes you who you are
in a way you know most of the time at
least like you know like 80
80 90 i'm part of the 80 90 yeah for
sure
like you could tell me to stop saying
the n-word or this and that but as soon
as the
i start rapping or this now and i go
back to my regular life that's who i am
i'm still be like that to the until i
[ __ ] some
has that ever costed you any
opportunities or features or
relationships
not that i know of yeah it could be
someone didn't want to [ __ ] with me
because of that but
i didn't do that you just don't know
about it yeah